Key question between, going between analysis and design is how we are going to
maintain these invariants. What maintains means is how,
once the invariance is broken, you will propagate the knowledge of the break to
the appropriate components so they can take steps to re-establish the invariant.
We can call these invariant maintenance strategies, or we can just say.
How are you going to implement this? And in particular,
we're going to have examples of three invariant maintenance strategies.
The first one is aggregated responsibility. That is, a single component is going
to be responsible for managing this process even if it has to invoke or
make use of several other components. That single component's responsible for
handling the external events after delegating the inherent maintenance to
the appropriate subordinate components. That's Strategy One.
Strategy Two is the opposite distributed responsibility. Each component knows
about the dependent components and anything that it's responsible for managing.
And invokes them when this state changes. And third invariant maintenance
strategy which is called the mediated responsibility or mediated strategy, okay?
It involves a special implementation element called a mediator, and
it's provided, it's one mediator for each invariant. The mediator knows all.
Okay, it knows about the both the independent and dependent participants and
the invariant. The independent one is the one that gets informed when
the initial event takes place. And the dependent ones are the ones that have to
respond to it. Three strategies, aggregated in one place,
distributed, or a new component, a mediator, responsible for dealing with it.